dimanche il est 16 heures le docteur
villiers vient démarré sa garde à la
maison médicale de montigny il est
accueilli par sa consoeur qui elle
termine la garde du matin tout
s'enchaîne
le docteur didier doit appeler le 15
pour prévenir de sa présence et winter
villiers je prends la relève à la maison
médicale de guyancourt montini voisins
et la garde est parti pour quatre heures
pendant la première tranche horaire le
médecin de garde a reçu 14 patients il
s'agit de la médecine générale précise
il s'agit pas de l'urgence vitale il
s'agit pas non plus de faire le
certificat médical sportif
il s'agit d'assurer la permanence des
soins pour un certain nombre de
pathologies qui dont il est préférable
qu'elle n'attende pas ou alors pour des
situations pour lesquelles il est besoin
d'un avis médical pour savoir s'il faut
aller à l'hôpital par exemple la maison
médicale de montigny le bretonneux
existe depuis dix ans tout le monde peut
y accéder après une régulation assurée
par le 15 qui donne le code d'accès le
secteur couvre notamment montini
guyancourt et voisins l'idée est née
d'une volonté de médecins de se
regrouper pour assurer une permanence de
soins en dehors des horaires d'ouverture
des cabinets médicaux classiques
c'est-à-dire le soir le week-end et les
jours fériés 45 médecins adhèrent à ce
réseau l'idée c'est qu'il ya plein de
gens qui vont à l'hôpital aujourd'hui
qu'ils n'ont pas y aller alors ils y
vont pour des pathologies bénignes ils
devront souvent parce que il y à une
dispense d'avancé de frais ça c'est
clair ils y vont parce qu'ils pensent
qu'on va leur faire pleins d'examen
comme c'est l'hôpital on fait plein
d'examen ça coûte une fortune ce sont
souvent des choses qui ne sont pas
nécessaires en 2012 la maison médicale a
traité plus de 4000 acte pour seulement
une quarantaine d'hospitalisation
philippe belet souffre de fièvre et de
courbatures il est venu accompagné de
son épouse
je me suis dit que ça ne nécessitait pas
vraiment les urgences mais qu'il fallait
qu'il voit un médecin
donc du coup quand j'ai regardé sur
internet et que j'ai vu que c'était à
côté j'ai été rassuré l'hôpital avec le
temps d'attentes avec le trajet surtout
son
un enfant malade et c'est vraiment
pratique la maison médicalisée sécurisé
c'est à deux pas de chez nous on habite
à montigny la formule fait donc ses
preuves
elle permet de désengorger les urgences
médicales et le ministère de la santé
verrait d'un bon oeil que ce système de
maison médicale soit étendue à d'autres
communes alentours jusqu'à versailles et
cela les médecins n'y sont pas
favorables
plus nous allons être nombreux plus la
logistique va être lourde plus ça va
être compliqué alors que notre projet
initial et ben c'est de nous entraider
entre nous et on avec tout un système de
confiance de choix entre nous qui fait
qu'on est parfaitement tranquille c'est
un collègue ami qui prend la garde là ça
devient quelque chose de beaucoup plus
difficile à gérer avec l'ouverture d'un
autre cabinet à l étage des listes de
garde beaucoup plus compliqué à faire
la consultation de journée s'établit à
49 euros 50 65 euros 50 pour le soir les
médecins perçoivent une indemnité
forfaitaire versée à chaque garde à
laquelle s'ajoutent leurs honoraires
actuellement dans les yvelines il existe
trois maisons médicales fixe et une
maison médicale dit mobile sur le
secteur de rambouillet